a principios del siglo 20 había un 4 por
ciento de población zurda en 1976 había
un 14% y no es porque las personas
zurdas no existían a principios de siglo
sino porque como se pensaba que era una
maldición se les invisibilizada esto es
lo que pasa hoy en día con los niños y
jóvenes trans
hace unos meses en el grupo de autoapoyo
al que asisto dos miércoles al mes grupo
en el que padres y madres compartimos
nuestras experiencias para ayudar a
otros padres y madres en su proceso de
tránsito se nos pidió que hiciéramos un
ejercicio de escritura terapéutica el
ejercicio consistía en escribir una
carta a nuestros hijos
mirando una foto de cuando eran peques y
otra en el momento actual
mi corazón y mis recuerdos me dictaron
lo siguiente
querido hijo hace más de dos años y como
nos ha cambiado la vida miro tu foto con
cinco años y ahora puedo ver que eres tú
que siempre has sido tú aún con tu
mirada triste eras tú aunque aun con tu
expresión seria eras tú tu siempre me
que woody rayo mcqueen el papá jugando a
cocinitas o con los carritos de muñeca
seguía pasando el tiempo y tú seguirás
cambiando tu pelo corto siempre ropa
deportiva pantalón y camisa en tu
comunión
note que los cambios que se iban
produciendo no te gustaban odiabas cada
regla y tu pecho cada vez te encogían
más para no mostrarlo
y con todas estas pistas no te vi aunque
me asaltaba la duda había algo a lo que
no sabía poner nombre algo que no
encajaba seguiste creciendo y ese algo
siguió creciendo contigo algo que sin
saber lo que era
te hacía especial y a la vez diferente
siempre he querido y respetado por todos
siempre luchando por conseguir hacer
todo lo que te gustaba siempre por ti
mismo autodidacta malabares los cubos de
rubik magia nada nada se te ponía por
delante y entonces un día cuando
cumpliste 16 años me diste la pieza para
encajar el puzzle lo hiciste en forma de
carta mamá soy un chico soy un chico
trans me escribiste y entonces te vi te
vi claramente pude ponerle nombre a
aquella pieza que nos faltaba para
encajar
transexual tengo un hijo transexual
no tengo una niña seria sino un niño
triste por no poder ser quien es
he de decirte que me lo pusiste todo muy
fácil
tenías buscada toda la información que
puertas tocar a qué sitios acudir qué
pasos seguir para el camino que
nos iba a llevar a tu felicidad
esa que poco a poco paso a paso con
algún tropiezo y muchísimas manos amigas
has conseguido
levantaste
tus hombros y tu cara para decir al
mundo aquí estoy este soy yo
tengo que agradecerte que confiar has y
confíes tanto en mí
te agradezco que no cambiará su nombre
porque un día te dije que era el único
nombre que había elegido para ti
[Aplausos]
después de este tiempo y de tu tránsito
tengo que decir y siempre diré que eres
una versión mejorada de ti mismo te
quiere mamá
yo pensaba que los niños trans no podían
existir nunca había visto ninguno
pensaba que ser trans lo decides cuando
eres mayor porque te gusta más ser
hombre o mujer después de este tiempo he
descubierto que ser trans no funciona
así ser trans es no sentirse
identificado con el género que te
asignan al nacer basándose en unos
genitales externos
y también sé que el género es quienes
somos
existen adultos trans porque antes
fueron niños trans solo que no estaban
visibles y qué podemos hacer para
cambiar esto
formar a médicos y demás personal
sanitario para que dejen de tratar a las
personas transexuales como enfermos
mentales ya que la transexualidad no es
ninguna enfermedad
cambiar contenidos en los libros de
texto
para que desde desde la edad infantil se
conozcan todas las diversidades y así
evitar
gran número de discriminaciones y acoso
según el último estudio de transcender
duro una de cada cuatro personas trans
ha intentado suicidarse en españa en el
último año
debemos instar a las instituciones para
que se cumplan las leyes y protocolos
autonómicos y debemos hacer una ley
estatal
para que nos acerque cada vez más al
derecho constitucional que dice que
todos somos iguales ante la ley y que en
españa tiene una coletilla que es según
donde vivas por ejemplo en madrid no se
puede cambiar casi ningún documento
si no tienes cambiado tu nombre en el
registro cosa que no es nada fácil y que
puede llevar años no hay derechos
especiales para las personas trans sino
derechos que no se cumplen como porque
como el derecho a la identidad
las personas trans utilizan un nombre
sentido que normalmente no coincide con
el nombre registral
esto es un problema a la hora de asistir
a algún médico cambiar algunos algunos
documentos y cuando te llaman por
ejemplo las listas de clase con un
nombre con el que no te identificas
debemos comprender que la paleta de
colores va más allá del blanco o negro
debemos visibilizar a las personas trans
para que tan visibles se vuelvan
invisibles y formen parte de una
diversidad mucho más amplia y más rica
mi aportación a la diversidad
y a la sociedad es mi apoyo
incondicional a mi hijo ya que como dijo
un gran amigo y compañero activista los
padres y madres de personas trans somos
aliados del derecho a ser muchas gracias
[Aplausos]